le millième but de pelé c'était il ya
quelques mois
aujourd'hui c'est avec sa fille kelly
christina 4 ans et sa charmante épouse
rosemarie que le dieu du football se
trouve à paris
les plaies en ayant l'intention de
rester plusieurs jours dans la capitale
et 10 passes et même les fêtes de noël
pad escorte officielle pour accueillir
le roi mais ses admirateurs tout
simplement premier rendez-vous à la
porte de versailles à l'occasion du
salon de la compétition comme les grands
de ce monde pelé a dû satisfaire à la
conférence de presse on a parlé
récemment de votre venue en france pour
jouer au paris saint germain était
sérieux effectivement il ya eu des
contacts entre les dirigeants parisiens
et moi même ils m'ont invité à cette
occasion à porter les couleurs de leur
club mais mon contrat avec santos
n'était pas terminé et j'ai toujours
exprimé le désir d'acheter ma carrière à
santos le seul club que j'ai connu mon
utile dans sa carrière de footballeur
d'ici trois ans au maximum
j'abandonnerai définitivement mes
activités de fotolog en ce qui concerne
que les hommes d'affaires je compte
surtout développer mon job de relations
publiques dans une banque est monté une
manufacture d'articles de sport
le cadeau qui va acheter à madame pelé à
paris d'habitude c'est moi qui choisis
mais puisque rose marie est aussi à
paris c'est elle qui fera l'illettrisme